des images captées par une passante de
l'arrestation d'un homme en crise qui
donne froid dans le dos
de la tête aux pieds le suspect a été
menotté par les policiers du SPVM trois
personnes ont été retrouvées poignardées
à mort dans un même logement après que
des voisins eurent entendu des cris
retentir
parce que moi j'ai une famille de quatre
enfants selon nos informations le triple
missile est un drame qui implique les
membres d'une même famille incluant le
jeune suspect qui était connu pour avoir
des antécédents en matière de santé
mentale
mais j'habite juste en arrière puis et
ce stressant le devoir ça un coin c'est
pas Façonnable que quelqu'un de la
famille peut trouver à sa même même de
la famille c'est quelque chose si tu
souhaites très grave de penser que c'est
des choses passent ici à Canada surtout
aux endroits familiales l'enquête
criminelle s'annonce longue et complexe
pour le SPVM qui prévoit prendre la nuit
entière pour analyser la scène de crime
qui se situe à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de l'immeuble les enquêteurs
qui vont prendre en charge la scène de
crime ils vont faire appel sûrement avec
les techniciens identifiés PVM les
réactions politiques n'ont pas tardé à
l'annonce du triple missile un peu
partout dans le monde il y a de plus en
plus de drame on investit davantage en
santé mentale il y a un défi de
recrutement que ce soit des travailleurs
sociaux des psychologues pour prendre le
temps des former la mairesse de Montréal
Valérie plante c'est aussi exprimée sur
les réseaux sociaux en offrant ces
condoléances aux proches des victimes
selon nos informations tous les
policiers et pompiers qui sont entrés
les premiers dans le logement où se
trouvait les victimes ont été placés
sous le programme d'aide psychologique
de leur employeur respectifs ici Pascal
Robida Radio-Canada Montréal